today we'll be explaining every former
and current hashira in the demon slayer
car let's get started number 12. kane
kocho
kane was the former flower pillar of the
demon's lair core as well as the sister
of the former insect pillar she was
slain several years prior to the present
story the kocho sisters lived a peaceful
privileged life with their wealthy and
loving parents who continuously doted on
and cared for them however this all came
crashing down when a demon attacked
their home their parents tried to
protect the two and were slaughtered
before their daughter's eyes they would
have been next but they were saved by
the timely arrival of geomehimejima who
killed the demon immediately before it
could kill either one of them after
these dramatic events the two sisters
made a promise to both join the demon
slayer core to stop the demons from
inflicting the same horror and pain they
experienced on others both of them soon
became successful demon slayers after
completing their training and developing
their own breathing styles during her
time as a demon slayer kanei was a
flower-breathing user that was skilled
enough to hold the position of the
flower hashira a position only reserved
for demon slayers who have slain one of
12 kazuki or have successfully battled
enslain at least 20 demons one day while
traveling through a village kane took
notice of a little girl being dragged
along by a leash by a man even though
the girl was nameless dirty and didn't
speak kane approached her and attempted
to convince the man who purchased her to
let her go when he demanded money and
compensation shinobu flung money in the
air grabbed the rope he released and ran
off with the girl they then took her to
the butterfly mansion adopted her and
named her kaneo when the girl proved
unresponsive without orders kane gave
her a coin to flip to help her make
decisions until she could make decisions
on her own some years later kane ran
into the upper rank 2 of the 12 kazuki
doma she was fatally wounded during the
encounter but he was forced to flee from
the rising sun before he could devour
her as she lay dying in shinobu's arms
she tries to convince her sister to
leave the demon's lair core to live a
normal life but her sister is dead set
on avenging her with the last of her
strength kanye described doma to shinobu
before succumbing to her wounds number
11. shinobu kojo shinobu is a demon
slayer of the demon slayer core and the
current insect feshira despite not
possessing the physical strength to cut
off a demon's head commented out of an
average demon slayer shinobu uses her
creativity ingenuity and other physical
abilities to make up for it instead of
the traditional method of decapitating a
demon with a niche and blade to kill
them shinobu opts to use a modified
version of a katana that acts as a
stinger to inject lethal wisteria poison
that is poisonous to demons shinobu is
present when kagayubi yashiki receives
news of the situation unfolding at
natagumo mountain and is given the order
to travel there and assist the lower
ranked swordsman
much later shinobu appears before he
heavily injured zenitsu greeting and
asking him if he is alright she then
suddenly appears behind the daughter of
rui's demon family wishing the creature
a good evening and commenting on the
beauty of the moon that night startled
the demon attacks the demon slayer with
their strings but shinobu dodges them
all effortlessly after a conversation
with the demon shinobu tells the elder
daughter demon that in order for them to
be friends and to satisfy those who have
died she will have to endure punishment
explaining in gruesome detail what she
had in mind for this and adding that the
creature won't die from it so there will
be no after effects enraged the demon
attacks shinobu again but the demon
slayer quickly bypasses her
simultaneously landing her insect
breathing attack on the creature she
laments the demon's poor choice turning
and subsequently watching as the
creature collapses she later attempts to
attack tanjiro and nezuko but her attack
is deflected by giu she questions his
interference noting that if he continues
this course of action everyone would
hate him the insect ashira asks her
fellow demon slayer to get out of the
way apologizing to him when he replies
that he isn't hated she turns her
attention to tonjiro telling him that he
is protecting a demon and that he should
get away from her the young demon slayer
explains that nezuko is his sister
causing shinobu to pity her and plant a
killer with a toxin that inflicts no
pain a while later during a final battle
inside the infinity castle that muzon
had created shinobu enters a room and
discovers doma eating a group of his own
female disciples shinobu angrily
inquires if he remembers the hiyori that
originally belonged to her elder sister
doma finally remembers her by the
butterfly wing design hayori that kane
once wore and playfully expresses his
disappointment and not being able to eat
kane due to the sun rising the insect
ashira swiftly launches an attack at him
using her insect breathing to inflict a
powerful stab directly into doma's right
eyeball which impresses him since he
couldn't block it shinobu hopes that the
poison will be effective enough to kill
him but then learns that doma had
already received information regarding
her poison from her battle against the
spider family now hedging her bets on
injecting a large dose to kill him by
using a six-stab attack shinobu strikes
him using insect breathing and
successfully hits him however as she
attacks him he simultaneously attacks
her cutting both her collarbone and ribs
and puncturing one of her lungs however
doma recovers almost instantly from her
attack by which shinobu is further
enraged now exhausted fatally injured
and dangerously near death she allows
herself to be absorbed by the upper rank
so she could poison him number 10 jigoro
kuajima jigoro was the instructor of
zenitsu and kaigaku as the former
thunder hashira he's currently an
elderly so his strength was
significantly waned due to the passage
of time but as a master of the secret
techniques of demon slaying he still
holds a considerable amount of knowledge
that he can pass down to the next
generation kaigaku managed to master all
of the thunder breathing forms except
the first form meanwhile zenitsu had
only managed to master the first form
and none of the others due to his
inexperience he committed seppuku when
his former student kagaku defected to
gain the powers of a demon after zenith
managed to kill kagaku zenitu and jigoro
briefly meet in the afterlife his
student apologized for not being able to
get along with kagaku before zenitsu is
forcefully returned to the land of the
living jigoro declared that zenitu was
his pride and joy with tears in his eyes
number 9. mitsuri kenroji mitsuri is a
demon slayer of the demon slayer core
and the current love hashira she is said
to have completed the final selection
within a mere six months of training
which kyogiro considers outstanding
mitsuri was born among five siblings and
displayed an unnatural strength at a
very young age through her unique muscle
composition shocking even her mother who
herself was known for her strength she
grew up eating much more than the
average person and developed an
unnatural hair color which led her to be
seen as a freak and unable to proceed
with a previously intended marriage when
she was 17. after this rejection she
dyed her hair black pretended to be weak
and forced herself to eat a normal
amount and attempt to fit in more with
other girls even if it negatively
impeded her well-being shortly after
making these adjustments to her physical
appearance mitsuri was approached by a
potential partner however she became
doubtful over whether or not pretending
to be a different person would truly
work out for her in the end mitsuri then
encountered kagaya who told her to
reject normalcy and embrace who she was
as her strength was a gift because of
this encounter she joined the demon
slayers and used her skills and
ridiculous strength to rise to the
status of hashira at the ubuyashiki
estate mitsuri thinks about the
potential killing of nezuko with
uneasiness the love hashiro's expression
of praise quickly turns to horror as
sonomy stabs nezuko but just as quickly
turns to laughter when tandro headbutts
him in the swordsmith village arc
mitsuri meets with tangero and nezuko in
swordsmith village when the village is
attacked by upper rank 4 and 5 mitsuri
quickly returns to the swordsmith
village from her own district when
tandra was swallowed by one of the tree
dragons mitsuri slices the creature's
head in half carrying tantra on her back
safely she squeals at the monster's size
and questions what it is then asks
tonjero if he's all right and that it's
a good thing that she made it in time
after putting tangero down she tells him
to rest and doesn't hear him try to tell
her that the demon is upper rank 4.
mitsuri continues to battle against
zohat kutin and uses her love breathing
forms to fight it the demon realizes
that she is too fast and is keeping up
with his attacks making him have to use
his blood demon art ability the love
hashira is then fiercely hit by
zokujin's compressed sound waves and
loses consciousness she is then
unconsciously awakened and obtained her
demon slayer mark when this manifested
missouri's physical strength endurance
precision and power increased
dramatically to the point where she was
able to stand equal grounds against
upper rank 4 while he was unleashing his
most powerful techniques against her
right as mitsuri feels as though she's
going to die tondro kills the main body
and zohakutan crumbles to dust a while
later during the final battle mitsuri
and obani fight against nakime mitsuri
immediately enrages the upper rank and
tries to behead her with presumably a
love breathing technique but nakimi
reflects the attack with her blood demon
art and warps a wooden door in between
the two of them fortunately mitsuri was
able to save herself by slashing open
the column which gave her an opportunity
to dodge the crush mitsuri wall jumps
off the column and tells nakime that she
knows she won't be able to hit her with
the same exact attack twice later
mitsuri dies while fighting with the
rest of the demon slayers against muzon
number eight mucha of tokito muchuro is
a demon slayer of the demon slayer core
and the current miss tashira he is noted
to be incredibly talented despite his
young age accomplishing his shashira
status after a mere two months of
training muchiro and his older brother
yuichiro were born to a woodcutter and
his wife when they were 10 years old
their mother caught a cold which
developed into bronchitis killing her
their father who had gotten to fetch
medicinal herbs for their mother during
a storm ended up falling off a cliff to
his death the two orphan siblings
survived together with muichiro taking
after the emotional and kind nature of
their father contrary to him yuichiro
held a cold and impassive outlook on
life in the following spring kagaya's
wife amani arrived to recruit the twins
for the demon slayer core muchiro's
excitement was opposed by yuichu's
unwelcoming and rejecting reception in
an outburst yuichiro revealed that he
blamed the death of their parents on
their hard-working and selfless natures
which led to him adopting this cold
demeanor hoping that it would keep
himself and his brother alive while
amani continued to visit the twins uee
road chased her away each time in the
following summer when the twins were 11
a demon arrived at the cabin during the
night and attacked resulting in urethra
losing his left arm while trying to
protect murichiro as the demon badgered
them for the worthlessness mucho lost
himself in rage and destroyed the demon
with all the tools at their disposal and
wooden logs by sunrise the demon
withered to ash and mucho dragged
himself back to the house there he found
you each road near death praying to the
heavens that his brother might survive
he laid next to his brother and grasped
his hand as he passed away after tondero
is brought to the hoshiro's meeting for
interrogation muchuro is present and
later introduced as the mrshira when
questioned about how he felt about
neziko being kept alive he retorted that
he did not mind and would forget about
the circumstance anyways when tanjore
suddenly interrupts kageya in the middle
of his meeting with the hashiras mitrov
flicks him in the head with the pebble
and advises him not to interrupt their
master in the swordsmith village arc we
see a battle between richaro and the
upper rank 4 hantengu muitro immediately
attacks on tengu using missed breathing
and cuts off his head tantro yells at
muchoro to keep focusing as zontengoo
splits into two bodies sekido and karaku
after being blasted out of the building
and into the forest by kiraku mitro
encounters upper rank 5 gyoko he tries
to attack him but gets trapped in his
blood demon art water poison pot after
escaping from the water poison mucho's
memories of his past all come back the
anger over his brother's death manifests
into his demon slayer mark his speed and
abilities dramatically increasing as he
goes into the shed and attacks kyoko who
comments on his relaxed face when gyoko
tries to find him in a sea of mist
muchoro effortlessly decapitates him at
the battle of the infinity castle mutual
was separated from gyome by upper rank 4
nakimi's blood demon art as mutual is
getting back up he sees a petrifying
six-sided figure the figure gazes at
muijiro and discerns that the hashira is
a familiarity to him muchuro soon
realizes that he is looking at the
infamous upper rank 1. kokushibo in the
flesh kokushibo sees the muscles ribs
and blood flow muichiro and determines
that mutro is of similar blood to him
mutro attempts to behead kokushibo with
his missed breathing the upper rank
however dodges it elegantly and admires
mucho swordsmanship skills along with
realizing that his descendant uses the
missed breathing mitro is not interested
in another conversation with the
so-called ancestor and unleashes his
missed breathing fifth form on the upper
rank which obeys the attack again with
no difficulty kokushibo calls me jaro's
name and that despite his incredibly
young age of 14 his swordsmanship skills
are this refined and beautiful mutual
soon dies at the hands of the upper
ranked one since the demon is far
stronger than muitro number seven obani
aguro obanai is a demon slayer of the
demon's lair core and the current
serpent hashira obanai is one of the
most powerful and skilled swordsmen in
the entire organization obani was born
into a clan of thieves who lived off an
excessive amount of riches that had been
stolen from those who had been killed by
the demon that they worshipped this
demon took the form of a woman with a
snake-like lower body and face and had a
great taste for newborn babies which is
what the family sacrificed in exchange
for their riches as the first boy born
into the family for 370 years obernight
lived out all his days locked in a
wooden cage being spoiled by his family
who insisted on bringing him so many
plates of rich food the serpent demon
also took a liking to obani since he was
a rare male child with heterochromia and
would spend the night slithering around
his cage in the dark staring at him
which frightened obama nice so much that
he couldn't sleep when he turned 12
overnight was finally allowed to leave
his cell for the first time in his
entire life he was taken to a room that
appeared to be an expensive shrine and
put face to face with the surfing demon
for the first time immediately causing
him to shake in fear and terror at the
demon's appearance and the realization
that this was the very same thing
slithering in his room staring at him
every night of his life the demon
remarked that obanite was very small and
wondered to herself if she would wait to
eat him until he was a little bigger
deciding that she should she organized
his mouth to be cut wider all the way to
his ears to match hers due to her liking
him back in his cell overnight began
only to think of escape and survival
upon realizing his fate he began to
scratch away at the lattice of his cell
with a stolen hairpin he took from one
of his relatives day by day he would be
in a constant state of worry and fear
and shaking in terror at the possibility
of what would happen if the snake demon
or his family would discover his
attempted freedom the only being he
could trust was the small snake that
sent him straight into his gauge and
became his only friend after a while of
doing this obani finally managed to
completely remove a wooden chunk of his
bars and escape into the night as fast
as he could as he ran the serpent demon
began to pursue him almost catching up
to him and killing him before the flame
hashera by chance came to his rescue
because of obani's escape the serpent
demon had killed all 50 of his relatives
and the only surviving member of his
bloodline was his older cousin who had
already been saved by the hashira when
they were reunited openid's cousin
rejected him and began to violently
attack and clawed him due to her blaming
him for the family's deaths at the hand
of the demon due to them messing up and
allowing him to escape and screaming at
him that he should have just let her eat
him due to these harsh words from his
cousin and his own sense of
self-loathing and guilt for having been
born into such a family and allowing
them to die for his survival obenite
joined the demon slayer core and decided
to turn all his rage into whatever
demons he could find figuring that he'd
feel like a better person if he risked
his life for the sake of others and
somehow eases guilt
during the hashira training he taught
swordskill revision training to the
other demon slayers further showcasing
his skill with the sword when tanjore
insists nezuko would never harm humans
despite turning into a demon the snake
asherah tells him not to make such
reckless remarks as the girl would
obviously protect her family and as such
he could not trust anything the young
demon slayer says after sonomy purposely
injured himself to bait out nezuko
openeye reminded his fellow hashira that
he would have to get out of the sunlight
in order for her to appear he then
swiftly pinned on through to the ground
to prevent him from interfering
maintaining his hold despite shinobu's
protests obanai rushes to the ubyashiki
estate with the rest of the hasheras
after hearing the call that muzan was
there after seeing luzon obani readies
himself to unleash his first form on him
but muzan transports him and the rest of
the hashira into his infinity castle
openai runs into missouri and kills a
group of demons with the serpent
breathing fifth form slithering serpent
later he and mitsuri encountered nakime
after missouri tries to attack and was
sent tumbling out of a window opening
tries to use the serpent breathing to
decapitate the demon however he too is
sent out of a window expressing in a
frustrated fashion how much of a pain
nakami's blood demon art is to deal with
after fighting with nakime for a while
openeye and mitsuri are informed of
muzan's revival and receive orders to
group up with the other hashira as mazan
groves furious over nakima's failure the
battle between the demon slayers and
muzan resumes during a long battle with
muzan obani gets heavily injured many
times as bazong grows furious opening
considers that he needs to find a more
effective way to attack thinking back on
the report that mitrov had turned his
blade red during his final moments he
speculates that by gripping the sword as
hard as you can you can increase the
temperature of the blade and thus turn
it crimson red in that moment his demon
slayer mark appears and he grips his
sword turning it bright red after
battling muzon again he dies alongside
mitsuri number six tengen uzui
tenganuzui is a current sound to shira
he has displayed incredible physical
feats of strength and speed being one of
the physically strongest shashira in the
current generation as well as being the
fastest runner out of all the hashira
tengen was born into a family of nine
children within a shinobi clan three of
the nine children died before they even
reached 10 years old due to overzealous
training by the age of 15 seven of his
siblings had already died leaving only
him and his younger brother as children
his father had forced them to undergo
harsh and intensive training as an
attempt to save the clan as his last
remaining brother adopted this mindset
and did not feel bad about killing their
other siblings tengen became appalled
and decided to leave the clan
permanently he left the village with his
wives without fighting his brother
following the departure from the clan
tengen and his family searched for
kagaya ubuyashiki to help fight for the
demon slayers and he formally joined
tengen would later go on to climb the
ranks of the core and become the sound
of shira tenkan was present as a member
of the hashira when dandra kamado was
put on trial upon finally meeting neziko
and tanjiro he openly expresses his
distaste at the idea of them traveling
together even claiming that he will cut
off his head with style tenga nuzui is
one of the main protagonists in the
entertainment district arc at the
beginning of the arc tengen enters
butterfly mansion and attempts to kidnap
naho and aoi to a system in his mission
however he is forced to change tactics
when the three boys tandro zenitsu and
inosuke rescue the girls and force him
to take them along on his mission on
their way to the site dengan reveals
that they are going to investigate the
disappearance of his wives within the
entertainment district in order to do so
he explains that each boy will be sent
to one of the three brothels to try to
gather information on their whereabouts
once they arrive at the district tengen
disguises the boys as girls and drops
them off at each house to begin their
investigation they discovered that the
demon they're looking for is upper rank
six daki tengen manages to quickly
decapitate daki unable to believe that
she is the upper rank that they have
been searching for upon discovering the
truth behind daki and gyotaro's presence
the hashira engages in fierce combat
with the demons gyotaro manages to
poison tengen during the fight
preventing him from decapitating the
demon after they finally managed to
bring down the demon siblings tengen
ends up losing his left hand and eye in
the process by the end of the battle
gyotaro's poison has spread throughout
tenkan's body resulting in his inability
to speak as he lays dying from the
poison nezuko intervenes by using her
blood demon art to burn the poison out
of his system allowing him to rejoice
with his wives once obinay arrives to
the scene he tells him that he is
officially retiring from the demon
slayer core because of his massive
injuries
number five kyoduro run goku kyojiro was
the former flame hashira even demons as
strong as akuza upper rank 3
acknowledged gyojiro's strength he even
went as far as to offer to turn kyojiro
into a demon so that he could surpass
his human limits and become stronger
something he only offered to swordsmen
whose abilities he believed were refined
to their utmost kyojiro is also one of
the main protagonists in the mugen train
arc kyoto is sent to investigate a
series of brutal attacks plaguing a
small village believing it to be related
to the incident surrounding the
disappearance of 40 passengers aboard
the mugen train once on the train he
meets with tanjiro zetnitsu and enosuke
the conductor then comes over to the
four of them to stamp their tickets
tangier smells something unusual and
kyojiro appears to sense it too as he
asks the conductor to step aside
simultaneously prepping his sword a
large body demon appears at the other
end of the carriage and kyogre wonders
if it was hiding with its blood demon
art before darting forward to behead it
with his flame breathing sometime later
when the four are all asleep kyoto
dreams that he's back at his house with
his father and brother in reality a
young girl who's working for enmu lower
rank 1 ties her wrist to his unconscious
body with a special piece of rope that
was made by the upper moon allowing her
to enter keojiro's dream the girl
locates his spiritual core but as she
goes to break it she's suddenly lifted
tightly by the neck by an invisible
force on the train kyoto grabs her
throat but remains unconscious his
survival instincts enabling his body to
sense a threat and stop it dante soon
wakes up from the dream he was having
and asks nezuko to burn the rope
connecting kyogiro and the girl removing
the girl from the hashira's dream after
the young demon slayer's confrontation
with enmu hiyuro two wakes up and tells
tandro that he zenitu and nezuko will
defend the eight train cars from the
demon while tantra and nasuke go down to
the front of the train to defeat him
after nanasuke successfully defeated
edmund hugo applauds the young demon
slayer for his recently acquired ability
to use total concentration breathing all
the time and says that this is the first
step to him becoming a hashira just as
keojiro starts to tell tantro that he
doesn't need to push himself any further
because everyone's been saved something
jumps down just behind the two demon
slayers with a great force scattering
the dust around them the dust clears to
reveal upper rank 3 akaza who
immediately launches himself towards
dangerous with the intention of killing
him but is stopped by kyojiro the
hashera notes that akusa is attacking
from a distance punching into the air
and moving out a fraction of a blink and
realizes that he'll have to get closer
to him if he's to defeat him kyoto
suddenly appears in front of akuza who
compliments his reaction speed as the
hashira attacks him with his flames the
upper rank praises his sword skills and
wonders to kyoto how sad it'll be if
they're lost early to which the hashiro
replies that it won't be sad because
it's only natural for people to die the
two clashed again and akisa managed to
pierce the kyrgyz or his chest with his
hand heavily wounding him akusa fled the
scene as the sun was about to rise
kiyojiro looks over at tanjuro and
smiles telling him to come over so they
can have a final chat before he dies
number four sukonji orokodaki sakonji
rokodaki is a retired member of the
demon slayer core having held the
position of the previous water hashira
he is the main cultivator of the water
breathing having trained gyotamioca
tandro kamado sabido and makamo having
received a letter from gyutamyoka
requesting that he trained tanjaro which
also explained the boy into sister
circumstances tsukoji set forth from his
home to find the two upon finding them
he stops tanjore from killing a demon
with his knife stating that the boy will
be unable to kill the creature with such
a blunt weapon admonishing the youth for
his question of how to properly defeat
the beast the elder watches as tanjo
struggles to come up with a way to
dispatch the creature sniffing the youth
sukkoji determines that he is no good as
he steals the scent of kindness even
when confronted by vile demons tsukoji
eventually agrees to test the boy to see
if he is worthy of becoming a demon
slayer telling him to bring his sister
and follow him sakoji then swiftly makes
for his home with dondero struggling to
keep his pace after arriving at their
destination the elder tells the
exhausted youth that the test begins now
instructing him to hike up the mountain
he travels with the boy partway up the
mountain telling him that he must make
his way back to his home before dawn he
then vanishes into the heavy fog
surrounding him sukoji explains his
profession as a cultivator to tanjuro as
well as how to join the demon slayer
core to prepare him for his trial and to
see if he is worthy of even being able
to participate in it sukhoji begins to
train tanjuro in the way of the sword
finally after a year has passed the
elder tells townsrow that he has nothing
more to teach him instructing him to
prove himself by improving the basics he
has been taught he then leads the youth
to a huge boulder telling him that if he
can cut it in half he'll be permitted to
go to the final selection when tantra
hesitates overcome by doubt sakonji
leaves without a word his hand in the
boy's training completed much later
after tanjo finally succeeds in slicing
the boulder in half sikonji explains his
reasons for not wanting tanzaro to go to
the final selection complimenting the
youth on his accomplishment he then
wraps the youth in a hug urging him to
come back alive from the final selection
after neziko's existence was discovered
by the demon's slayer core tsukonji
sends a letter to kagaya ubu yashiki in
it he requested tantro kamado be
forgiven for harboring a demon and
explains neziko's unique circumstances
number three sonomi shinozugawa sonomy
is the current wind hashira according to
kokoshibo sonami's physical abilities
and techniques have reached their peak
satomi was the eldest son of seven
children and lived with both of his
parents their father was abusive
constantly lashing out at the children
and their mother until one day he was
stabbed and killed by someone with a
grudge against him one day sonomy's
mother failed to return home so sonomy
left to search for her at some point he
found her and realized she'd become a
demon but couldn't stop her from
returning home and killing five of his
siblings just before she could kill
genya however sonomy tackles her through
a window to the street below with a
knife in hand in the ensuing fight she
gave him the two large scars across his
face and his marichi blood which
disorients demons and makes him act
intoxicated gave him an opening to cut
her down when genya runs into the street
to find a doctor for his grievously
injured siblings he finds sonomy with
their mother laying dead at his feet
panicking not knowing that the monster
that attacked them was their demonified
mother genya screams and accuses sonomyo
of murdering her sonomy still in shock
becomes partially colorblind as their
mother dissolves in the sunlight after
that sonomy abandoned genya and began to
hunt demons with his own suicidal
devotion without knowledge of demon
slayers or nature and swords sonomy
instead armed himself with a multitude
of weapons and fought demons at night
incapacitating and capturing them until
daylight then stringing them up to let
the morning sun kill them despite his
crude and reckless battle style he
managed to survive thanks to sheer luck
and the unique aroma of his blood while
wandering the land hunting demons he
eventually met a legitimate demon slayer
who helped him and introduced him to a
proper trainer the two of them teamed up
to defeat the then lower rank 1 of the
12 kazuki however his friend lost his
life in the battle and only sonomy was
promoted to the rank of wind teshira
sonomy arrives at the demon's slayer
headquarters where tondro has been put
on trial coming in holding neziko's box
he is finally introduced to the latter
sonomy mocks tanzero for carrying a
demon around with him and proceeds to
draw his blade before stabbing the box
enraged tanjo charges at him and manages
to headbutt him however before they
could continue the fight the leader of
the demon slayers arrives to begin the
trial tsunami's tone immediately changes
as he greets kagaya politely introducing
dondero who is being put on trial for
traveling with a demon to everyone's
surprise kagaya explains that he has
already accepted the kamado siblings
tsonomy along with the other hoshira
immediately refused to accept the
decision he pulls out his blade and cuts
his arm causing his blood to drip sodomy
proudly proclaims that he will prove
their leader wrong proceeds to pour his
blood into nezuko's box openeye reminds
sonomy that the demon won't come out in
the sunlight so he quickly moves into
the building behind kagaya drawing his
sword prompting tanjuro to attempt to
come to his sister's aid sonomy stabs
nezuko's box multiple times prompting
her to leave it seeing the hashira's
wounded arm she is transfixed by the
sight of blood distracted from the
temptation before her nezuko remembers
her order not to hurt humans with much
effort she turns away from a shocked
sonomy during the infinity castle arc
while demon slayers battle against
kokushibo sonomi rescues his brother
genya by reflecting the upper rank's
attack with his wind breathing kokushibo
makes his distance and sees that the win
to shira sonomy has come in his presence
sanemy agrees with the upper rank that
he is indeed the win to shira and that
he'll be the win to shira that'll rip
off his head sonomy tells genya that he
should have never joined the demon
slayer core and then he should have had
a wife and children and vowed to protect
them this makes genya shed tears as
sanomi expresses his true feeling
towards him as kokushimo jumps into the
air sonome uses the wind breathing first
form and kokushibo draws his sword in
order to block the attack later sonemy
awakened his own mark that resembled a
windmill with two dots on both sides on
his right cheek the mark dramatically
increases his power and ability as seen
when sonomy was still able to fight and
contend with kokushibo on the ground
despite being grievously injured and
slashed across his abdomen however even
though his physical endurance strength
and tolerance have been dramatically
increased he couldn't land a significant
hit on kokoshibo without assistance from
guillaume and uichiro number 2.
gyotamioca
is the current water hashira giu grew up
alongside his older sister tsutaku
tomioka when he was still a child his
sister sacrificed herself to protect him
from the demons giul was 13 years old
when he met sabito while training under
sakonji and they became good friends
through their similar pasts and age
together they entered the final
selection giul was injured after a
demon's attack and was saved by sebido
who defeated nearly every demon on the
mountain however after the week went by
it was revealed to you that sabito was
the only one who died during their
selection as a result of this guz
started developing a doubt for the
authenticity of his position after
becoming the water hashira while tanjore
was struggling to fend off the attack
from his demon turned sister gio attacks
the ladder from behind only to fail as
tanjura moves nezuko out of the way
recovering quickly the swordsman asks
the boy why he protected the demon and
he replies that the demon is his sister
gil possesses inhuman speed and reflexes
as shown when he took nezuko away from
tanjo's grasps at blinding speeds which
took him several seconds to register
seeing that nezuko was not like other
demons giyushi this sword incapacitating
the unusual demon with a bare-handed
blow to the neck he would later send a
letter to sukhonji requesting for him to
train tanjiro and explaining the boy
into sister's circumstances after
receiving news of the many demon slayers
perishing on nataguma mountain kagaya
orders giu to assist with the lower
ranked swordsman upon arriving gyu saves
an escape from the father spider demon
by cutting off its arm and easily
beheading the demon with his water
breathing gew later intervenes in the
battle between tantro and lower rank 5
saving him for rui's blood demon art he
praises dondero for holding out so long
and that he would take care of the rest
rui expressing great annoyance over the
appearance of another demon slayer
attempts to use blood demon art on the
hashira gyu nullifies the attack with
his own water breathing cutting apart
all the threats while rui is in shock
over how easily the technique cut
through his threads goo swiftly beheads
him shinobu suddenly appears and tries
to attack nezuko gyu asks if tanjo can
move and tells him to run which the boy
does while simultaneously thanking him
and apologizing during infinity castle
arc gee was seen with the other hashira
attacking muzan he eventually enters
nakimi's infinity castle alongside
tangiero the two are soon ambushed by
akuza with geo quickly sent flying away
by aku's attack gyu soon returns angry
and finally manifests the mark as he
begins fighting akaza causing his speed
to increase akasa immediately matches
giza's new speed and eventually gains
the upper hand breaking gui's blade with
a punch as akusa goes in for the final
blow his hand is cut off by tanjore a
mid attack saving giu giu then
re-enrages zakusa once more but is
eventually defeated by akus's final form
giu then watches asakusa is beheaded by
tanjiro after akus's beheaded body
begins attacking tangero the injured
guild defends tanzero vowing to protect
tanjore with his life as he continues to
take damage after akus's death gyu falls
unconscious from fatigue alongside
donjero they both later battle against
buzan and upon defeating them giu is one
of the few hashiris to survive
number one kiyome himejima gyome is the
current stone hashira he is stated by
both tondro and nosuke to be the
strongest demon slayer in the entire
demon slayer car this is further given
credence by kokushibo who noted that
gyomi's natural physical abilities have
been trained at their absolute peak and
also stated that in the last 300 years
he has not encountered the warrior of
gyome's caliber before gyome was a demon
slayer and shashira he lived with nine
other children who were orphans and
raised them in the temple this area was
well known for demon attacks so gyome
had always burned wisteria incense to
ward off any demons that would harm him
and the children one night one of the
nine children disobeyed the temple rules
and traveled beyond its borders he is
immediately accosted by a demon and in
order to save his own life he tells the
demon to eat the other children
including gyome after night fell the
child invited the demon into the temple
after putting out the wisteria incense
four children were immediately killed by
the demon and the remaining children
insisted on escaping the temple ignoring
gyome's orders his frail structure and
blindness fueled the distrust that the
children had in yomi's ability to
protect them which led them to abandon
him and ultimately getting killed by the
demon in the end only one child the
youngest seo had listened and stayed
behind in fear of the demon though it is
unknown how the exchange went down
gyoume had been cut across the forehead
by the demon but soon reversed the
situation and began attacking the demon
mercilessly after realizing he had a
frightening amount of power he went on
and beat the demon's head until the sun
arose soon after people came to the
scene of the incident to help but due to
a misunderstanding the villagers thought
gyome killed the children and not the
demon he was later imprisoned and
charged with the murder of the seven
children but kagaya intervened and
released him before he would have been
executed for his crimes later on giome
became a demon slayer and after only two
months the stone hashira due to being
blind gyome has compensated and altered
his senses to adapt to his condition
effectively developing a superhuman
sense of hearing after the ubishiki
residence explodes gyome is there to
provide backup to tomeo after she
successfully injects muzan with her
medicine and cleaves the demon's head
clean off as muzanri generates his head
and uses his blood demon art to attack
kyomei the stone hishera counters with
the stone breathing to protect himself
he is then transported inside the
infinity castle along with the other
demon slayers during khashira's fight
against upper rank 1 kokoshibo uses his
moon breathing on sonomy as the dust
clears sonoma is nowhere to be seen and
gyome appears and says that the demon's
slayer core will never stop until all
demons are eradicated from the world
kokoshibo noticed that him uses the
sound of his chains rattling to tell the
exact position the chain is in and uses
that to guide his axe and flail during
combat as seen in this conversation with
kokushimo regarding the demon's lair
mark giome was able to accurately tell
that he was lying by detecting the
slight changes of the sound of his body
with him noting that he heard the ladder
shake after revealing his deception he
immediately tells sonomy to stitch his
stomach wound and to stay out of the
fight until he finishes after a long
fight with the help of the demon slayers
gyomi successfully defeats kokushibo
with genya completely gone sonemy
screeches and shouts his name in mental
agony not wanting to believe that his
brother is really gone gyomi interrupts
sonamy's grieving telling him that the
night isn't over and that muzan still
has to be defeated back at the
battlefield with tanjoro coming closer
to death the hashera gets slashed and
cut by muzan's attacks mitsuri gets the
worst in muzan's barrage and just as she
was about to get impaled by one of
muzon's arm tentacles a sudden impact
destroys the tentacle saving mitsuri it
soon turns out to be gyome coming to
everyone's surprise especially the demon
lords later gyome dies by the hands of
muzan but the demon's lairs managed to
defeat muzan once and for all